all right the president just wrapped up
a huge raucous fun rally in Indiana
we'll bring all the highlights
throughout the show here's just a small
sample of what went down take a look if
we would have told you during the
campaign that we would create 3.3
million jobs in the short time everybody
back there the fake news media look at
all
[Applause]
[Music]
there's big news
everybody back there would have said can
you imagine he's saying we're going to
create 3.3 million can you believe it
and you have to work every day between
now and November to elect more
republicans so that we continue making
America great again and by the way this
is a first for India our new slogan for
2020 you know what it is
Keep America gray all right what can I
have more on the president's rally in
just a moment but first a great day for
this country and our fellow countrymen
why because early this morning a plane
carrying three of our fellow Americans
who had been held hostage in North Korea
for months they touched down in Joint
Base Andrews our prayers were answered
these three men came back in good health
and we should all be proud of the
outstanding work this country did to
bring our fellow Americans home
president Trump he met the three former
hostages on the tarmac and delivered
these hopeful remarks about 3:00 a.m. in
the morning last night
excellent to these three incredible
people they are really three incredible
people
the fact that we were able to get him
out so soon was something really a
tribute to a lot of things including a
certain process that's taking place
right now and that process is very
important so we will see what happens we
have a meeting scheduled in a very short
period of time you'll be hearing about
it soon
we have the location set and we will see
if we can do something that people did
not think was going to happen for many
many years and a lot of bad things could
have happened in between now this was a
very important diplomatic victory we
know the danger that these three
Americans face because we saw what
happened to otto warmbier remember he
was the american college student he was
held captive in north korea which
ultimately caused his horrific death and
the warmbier family they remain in our
prayers tonight and tonight we have a
reason to feel hopeful and proud three
American lives were likely saved and we
didn't have to bribe Kim jong-un or send
pallets of cash to North Korea to get
the job done but some of the mainstream
media is corrupt as they are they barely
yawn today the New York Times initially
buried this story the ABC News will they
used the historic of development to
criticize President Trump on Iran then
there's of course the liberal senator
from New York Chuckie Schumer he was
less than pleased really three Americans
saved back home you know please you're
not happy take a look at this the
exultation by the president and others
of the greatness of North Korea doing
this evades me we can't be fooled into
giving the North Korean regime credit
for returning Americans that never
should have been detained in the first
place American citizens are not
diplomatic bargaining chips their
release should not be exalted it should
be expected it is no great
accomplishment of Kim jong-un to do this
and when the President does it he
weakens American foreign policy and puts
Americans at risk around the world
amazing about this a friend of mine he's
a great doctor he's a brain sir
talked about this earlier and he said
what a jerk and this is comes from one
of the smartest brightest brain surgeons
in the world Pete you're right all right
this is one sad case of Trump
derangement syndrome Trump a truckie
it's okay to be proud of your country
lives were saved
and while Schumer is wining president
Trump is continuing his push for peace
ultimately in the Korean Peninsula today
he made an important announcement he
tweeted quote the highly anticipated
meeting between Kim jong-un and myself
will take place in Singapore on June the
12th we will both try to make it a very
special moment for world peace and of
course we can't predict the future
and Kim jong-un is frankly an
untrustworthy unpredictable despot but
look where we are now given all North
Korea's concessions we have reason to be
cautiously optimistic tonight as the
Korean Peninsula is now progressing
towards peace tensions in the Middle
East they're rising as we were reported
to you last night the Israeli Defense
Forces announced that Iran in fact fired
over a dozen missiles from Syria into
Israel from their installations in Syria
no casualties thankfully were reported
the iron dome intercepted many of these
projectiles and just hours ago Israel
rightfully responding in a massive way
launching a full-scale aerial attack
against Iran's forces in Syria and they
took out dozens of military sites
anti-aircraft batteries and reportedly
killing dozens of those that are
committing these acts of terror and
unlike many countries Israel could never
put their guard down they don't have
that luxury when it rains on Israel
there will be a flood on Israel's
enemies now this conflict with Iran is
no different in fact Iran's involvement
and proxy wars all over the Middle East
has long been a threat to the security
and the peace of the Israeli people and
of course American troops that are
stationed in Syria Iraq and elsewhere
you have the mullahs of Iran have long
been chanting death to America death to
Israel burning our flag burning their
flag and they back up those words by
what funding the most radical terrorists
in the world sending trained fighters
all over the Middle East to kill our
soldiers in Iraq and our allies soldiers
this is a chief reason for the current
military strikes in Syria and likely
played a very
key role in president Trump's right
decision to pull out of that horrific
Iranian deal just a few moments ago the
president wrapped up this rally in
Indiana he spoke about Iran and North
Korea and so much more
take a look at a June 12 in Singapore
I'll be meeting with Kim jong-un to
pursue a future of peace and security
for the world for the whole world
but you remember everybody in the fake
news where they were saying he's going
to get us into a nuclear war
[Music]
and you know what gets you into nuclear
wars and you know what gets you into
other Wars weakness weakness I think
it's going to be a very big success but
my attitude is and if it isn't it isn't
okay if it isn't it isn't fun and you
have to have that because you don't know
we're not going to be walked into an
Iran deal where the negotiator john
kerry refused to leave the table Obama
President Obama
[Music]
paid 1.8 billion for hostages
you not me you last night you saw it and
again it's leading to some very big
things and I think that Kim Jong hoon
Kim Jong on did a great service to
himself to his country by doing this but
those hostages came out with respect we
didn't pay for them we're going to set
the table we're going to make a great
deal for the world for North Korea
vagina now while the president is
touting some of the very key
developments on the world stage the vice
president Mike Pence he is now backing
him up right here at home during an
interview earlier today the vice
president told ABC that it's time for
Muller's witch-hunt and i agree
completely to come to an end
take a look our administration has been
fully cooperating with the special
counsel I think his investigation is a
hoax and will continue to what I think
is that it's been about a year since
this investigation began our
administration has provided over a
million documents we fully cooperated in
it and in the interest of the country I
think it's time to wrap it up time to
wrap it up I agree and meanwhile
according to some stellar reporting
again from our own Sarah Carter we know
that the fired former FBI director James
Comey although one rod Rosenstein said
the fire he actually consulted with team
Muller before giving any testimony to
Congress about its inquiry into Russia
can anyone say collusion or
collaboration inappropriate now Judicial
Watch has actually acquired the emails
that show coordination in these efforts
between the Office of Special Counsel
and the disgraced former FBI director in
other words you have deep state news
here remember last night when we
reported the meeting between rod
Rosenstein Intel committee chair Devin
Nunez and oversight committee chairman
trey Gowdy well that meeting was
classified but it was supposed to
address the DOJ s ongoing stonewalling
slow-walking of documents that have been
subpoenaed by Congress own then they
give the phony redactions oh and then
they delay delay and delay and then oh
they say no but according to a brand-new
article from Sarah Carter this could be
just an effort to buy time processions
and Rosenstein we'll have more on this
later in the show this stuff is not
funny the American people have a right
to know the Constitution gives Congress
that oversight responsibility make no
mistakes we on this program we will hold
the Attorney General Jeff Sessions Rod
Rosenstein the Deputy Attorney General
and anyone else actively obstructing
constitutional congressional oversight
accountable and finally tonight
we have new developments surrounding the
confirmation process of president
Trump's pick to head the CIA her name
you see her right there an amazing
appearance before Congress she in a
hospital now Democrats are opposing her
because they think the enhanced
interrogation program she oversaw was
too tough on terrorists like Khalid
Sheikh Mohammed you know the guy that
was the mastermind behind 9/11 former
Vice President Dick Cheney he's not
buying it he's dead on accurate earlier
today he came out swinging good for the
former vice president watch this what we
did was in fact consistent with our
fundamental statutes and agreements that
were in place and and it worked I think
what we did help ultimately produce the
intelligence we needed to be able to get
bin Laden if it were my call I would not
miss continue those programs I'd have
them active and ready to go you tell me
that the only a method we have is please
please pretty please tell us what you
know well I don't buy that and I think
the techniques were used were not
tortured so now people want to go back
and try to rewrite history but if it
were my call I'd do it again of course
the Vice President Dick Cheney is right
the interrogation of Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed it led to the courier that
courier led us to where Osama bin Laden
was it is time for Democratic senators
to put the safety of you the American
people ahead of their personal hatred of
President Trump we need to confirm
people heroes like Gina Hass fell as
soon as possible without a doubt she is
an American Hero she is the right choice
to lead the CIA by the way Claire
McCaskill where are you Heidi Heitkamp
where are you on this we need a strong
CIA one that does not use the weapons of
intelligence against the American people
like we have been exposing on this
program